now onto a family of the royal kind
Harry and Megan we're talking about they
made their first joint visit to their
namesake County Sussex and as if we
needed another reason to love them both
well they go and do this ah
the Royals affection for dogs and kids
made their trip especially sweet Duchess
Megan petted an adorable puppy while
Harry beamed ear to ear while greeting
this shaggy guy and we'd have to say
that Harry is ready for future daddy
duty based on his interaction with local
school students and check out his facial
expression when meeting a cute little
baby priceless the two received a rock
star welcome to Sussex which is in the
southeast corner of England Megan looked
sleek and a cream Armani coat and green
leather hue a boss skirt her hair was
done up in her signature messy bun
during the visit the Duke and
american-born Duchess were shown a
historic copy of the US Declaration of
Independence and when they both signed
an official guestbook it was first names
only no need for last names or addresses
on a stop to a local university the two
officially opened a Technology Center
with Megan Megan safety goggles look
chic they were also treated to a
performance by a Youth Orchestra making
their day in Sussex a complete success
[Applause]
you
[Music]